Let's go next to our caller from the 6-3,
one area code who's calling today from 6 3
1.
David is.
Yes, it is.
Hi.
This is spinning chair from Long Island.
Thanks, Bernie.
Before you go on, if you can put the phone
a little further from your mouth because you're
absolutely maxing out our system and it becomes
hard to hear.
Just keep the phone a little further away
from your mouth, please.
And text right from here the other day.
I love it.
Yes.
The other day, you had a video about social
democracy and populism that I found very interesting.
But I thought there was more to flush out
because you yourself do have an anti-establishment
criticism.
You know, you will criticize what you call
the Democratic establishment.
And I think that to an extent is populism.
So I don't know if you can kind of square
that circle because you do engage in some
populist arguments, but you do manage not
to, I guess, fall off the deep end with it.
I mean, I guess I don't.
There's really no conflict between.
So the analysis was basically an analysis
of it's harder to pervert and bamboozle with
social democracy than with populism.
That was my assertion, essentially.
And as I said in the video, that doesn't mean
left populist ideas are wrong.
So the way that I square it is I believe in
social, socially democratic policy.
And certainly there are good left populist
ideas and I have some of those ideas.
But the analysis was that it's very easy to
pervert populism and you end up with right
populism and it can even go into authoritarianism.
That was the analysis I made.
Maybe I'm not understanding the question,
but I don't know.
There's anything to square.
Oh, so in other words, you wouldn't say that
you have a somewhat populist analysis, but
that you don't go off the edge with that.
Like maybe a moderate populism, you would
just say that you're just a social Democrat.
Listen, the word getting into is sort of like
labeling everything.
I guess my general political views, economic
views are of of social democracy.
There is certainly overlap in terms of many
of the goals with left populism.
But the story was not so much about my views
per say, but about the ways in which populist
rhetoric has been perverted in many cases
and ends up being something very different
than what's promised.
OK, well, maybe if I could phrase it in a
different way.
I just lost my train of thought.
I'll head out now.
Have a good day, David.
All right.
Very good.
Appreciate the phone call.
Great to hear from you.
Yeah.
People, so we have dramatically improved our
phone system over the last two weeks where
we have a very small delay, as people can
probably tell.
The only downside is I have less of an ability
when that crunching sound happens, it's it's
in the system.
It's not on my end.
So people need to talk a little quieter and
maybe keep the phone a little further away.
Both very, very important elements of making
a good phone call right now